[Music]
I'm sorry I just didn't even feel
comfortable doing a silly joke like I
usually do at the beginning of this
video it just didn't seem appropriate
Fruitvale station stars Michael B Jordan
and Octavia Spencer now this film is
about a true story based off of
something that happened recently a few
years back and before I tell you the
plot let me just let you know the film
opens by telling you essentially how the
film is going to end so if you are
unaware of this true story that this
film is based upon and you don't want to
know what the film is about please don't
listen to me as I explain the plot
however the first scene in the movie
does tell you exactly what happened so
it's kind of spoiled in the plot
synopsis and it's not really something
that I can hide from you it's a true
story it happened this film is about the
last day in a man's life named Oscar
Grant this man was shot and killed by a
police officer in 2009 and this film
depicts the last day of his life and
what led up to that event now I went to
see this movie knowing that it was gonna
be a difficult film to watch but I can
honestly tell you that when the film
ended I went out into my car in the
theater parking lot and I just sat in my
car for like 10 minutes just looking at
the clouds and listening to music this
movie really left a true impact on me
the last 25 minutes of it or so my legs
were kind of jittery my heart was
beating fast I knew what was coming and
it really really hit me now with most
movies that are based on a true story
there's always gonna be some liberties
taken there's gonna be certain things
that necessarily didn't happen in real
life there's gonna be some added drama
that probably wasn't there to help
heighten the characters there are
certain scenes in the film that the
writer director has admitted to writing
himself that didn't actually take place
one of them involving a dog I understand
the meaning of that scene but when
you're trying to tell a story about a
character you're gonna want to flesh out
that character more you're gonna need to
have some drama in there and I
understand why he has admitted publicly
that certain scenes didn't actually
happen
I understand that but the full weight of
this picture and the drama that he was
trying to create is definitely there it
doesn't feel as if it's pounding it into
you it doesn't feel like it's just
assaulting you with some big message
that we're supposed to hate law
enforcement and love this guy's life
it's very truthful about the fact that
this person was kind of a criminal and
he was involved with things that weren't
necessarily the best things to be
involved with he had a daughter that he
was trying to care for he had a
girlfriend he was trying to care for but
he was involved in some shady things and
it led to a very very
horrible situation that happened that
many people were enraged by and
naturally now we have a movie about it
and I gotta say one of the best things
about this movie is Michael B Jordan his
performance is terrific and some of the
more intense scenes you can really see
it in his eyes that guy's a powerful
actor in the more subtle moments he does
a beautiful job and he really sucked us
into that character and made us care
about that character so the finale of
the film is all the more tragic it's
interesting to know how a film is going
to end and still feel this tension in
you building as it goes along because
you know certain things are coming and
when they hit it hits you hard and this
movie definitely got me the movie
suffers from a little bit of a pacing
issue due to the plot of the movie
really just being the sky's last day and
you see him really do everything and it
can get a little bit slow at times but
for the most part the performances in
this film the powerful direction the
good writing and the message of the film
really impacted me and just kind of
brought me down to earth and really made
me think a lot and this is not a movie
that you really want to see if you are
interested in having a good time if
you're going on a date this is
definitely the kind of movie that's
gonna stick with you it's gonna brood
inside you for a while it's gonna make
you feel some things but it definitely
does what it needs to do very well I
thought the movie was very well made and
very well acted I'm gonna give Fruitvale
station
an a-minus so guys if you saw the film
I'm interested in knowing what you
thought of it let me know below and as
always guys thanks very much for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]